how much a role if any that you feel
race and gender play in that well there
are polls that also say I have great
approval ratings hey guys I'm off the
grid for August this is a general intro
to a video of Democrats doing something
stupid there are reports that say that
you have the lowest approval rating of
any vice president I'm curious how much
of a role if any that you feel race and
gender play in that well there are polls
that also say I have great approval
ratings I think the point that has to be
made is that
there are attempts to create
distractions away from the
accomplishments of our Administration
we've created over 13 million jobs since
we've been in office
Joe Biden and I have been responsible
for eight hundred thousand new
manufacturing jobs in the United States
not to mention what we have done to
restore America's Integrity on the
international stage
foreign